hi everyone today we're going to look at
Turing nlg a 17 billion parameter
language model by Microsoft the latest
and greatest of language modeling by
Microsoft what is this it is a language
model a language model is basically a
model that learns to produce language
given this language so if you start a
sentence it's supposed to finish a
sentence if you start a paragraph it's
supposed to finish the paragraph that's
the language model ultimately you can
make it do different things like answer
questions have a conversation with you
anything to do with understanding
language the special thing about this
one is that it's gianormous
so if you look at the scale of kind of
language models so Bert was quite a
large thing in its back in its day ye
olde the Bert you can see here it has
about thirty three hundred forty million
parameters now I'll just say all of
these language models are transformers
this is kind of the state of the art
today so all of these are our account
our transformer based models then GP t2
here you can see that was the model that
was so large it was too dangerous to be
released into the world that stands at
one point five billion parameters
Megatron LM by Nvidia eight point three
billion and now we are at 17 billion
parameters for this language model and
it is a bit better so like people just
throw more and more and more resources
at this language problem and it really
yeah so what you can do with it
you can of course do a language modeling
so what happens is you take a bunch of
text like all of Wikipedia and all of
the internet and all of Reddit and so on
and you let the model train on it to
understand to basically produce that
sort of language and then you can
measure it for example it's it's a
perplexity on a validation
set and the Turing nlg is currently
state-of-the-art on that it can also do
for example question answering so you
can ask a question and give it a passage
about that question and it will then
tell you the answer that it deduced from
that passage given the question as you
can see here what is more interesting is
that a usual QA system will point to the
passage so it will point to the words
Tristan Prettyman whereas with a
generative model like this one what you
can do is you can make it actually
output an answer as a sentence so it
will generate the text jason mraz was
engaged to tristan pediment sorry
Prettyman if you ask a question without
giving it a context and just ask it to
generate an answer it will do so as well
I don't know if these answers are
cherry-picked
but they call this zero shot question
answering so if you ask when the world
were to end and it can output World War
two ended in 1945 simply out of
regularities it detected in the training
data so I mean that's what I'm kind of
wondering at what point are are these
models have do they have so many
parameters that they simply reproduce
the training data right I mean this
clearly some article from the training
data is about World War two or many are
and and he simply learned that following
a question when the world were to end it
needs to answer with the appropriate
passage I'm not sure that is a proper
measure of language understanding if you
simply can make more and more of the
training data into these many many
parameters but I'm not the judge of that
here
it can do it very well so yeah what I'm
actually more interested in is this
thing it's called the zero optimizer
that they used to train the model so the
model is just a transformer it's just a
big big transformer model there is
nothing really special about the model
except that it is larger than the last
model and therefore a bit better
what is interesting is that this would
have been pretty impossible to train if
it weren't for this zero optimizer of
this deep speed library and Microsoft
has released this deep speed library is
compatible for now with PI torch you can
check this out I'll put a link into the
description and we'll I want to dive
into this a bit there's a paper it's by
some young Rajah Bhandari and I'll and
by all by Microsoft the paper describes
in detail the optimizer but it's not
very visual that's why we're going to
the blog post you can see it gives many
speed ups over over usual over the
previous Megatron LM model that Nvidia
just trained using kind of just what
NVIDIA has is NVIDIA has machines that
are interconnected within the machine
with very fast very fast buses between
GPUs but this zero optimizer can now
also go over the network and make it
pretty fast so let's explore that a bit
I have the copy this here so we'll look
how the zero optimizer works so usually
what you do is if you have multiple GPUs
you can do something like this and this
is called data parallelism what you have
is you have a model and the model in
this case fits on your GPU it fits on a
single GPU so the
lü thing here is the model I'll actually
draw this itself here so the model let's
say is a somehow a neural network so it
has a bunch of layers layer layer layer
layer right and what you want to do is
you pass data forward here is some loss
and then right into the loss function
and then backward again that's basically
watch what you need to do you need to
pass it forward and backward in order to
do back propagation training right if
this all fits into one box that's
completely fine right if this fits into
one machine cool we can just put mini
batches of data through batch one batch
to batch three and so on
train the model if you want to do a
speed-up using this you can do so if you
have lots of data you can do what's
called and I'm always confused I think
this is called data parallelism or is it
called model parallelism because in any
case what you can do is you can take a
second machine or many of those
replicate the model now this these
models these two models here are exactly
the same
right but what you do is you take your
data and you split it up basically you
take double the amount of data and you
put one batch of data through the top
part and you put the other through the
bottom part and you do your forward
passes on the machines and you do your
backward passes and then what you want
to do is you want to sync between the
machines what they learned from the data
so each machine has a different set of
data points each machines calculates its
own a parameter updates it learns from
the data it has and then if they
communicate to keep because this here
and this here should be the same right
it's the same model so they have to keep
in sync now this can be usually can be
done fairly efficiently especially if
these aren't actually two machines but
just two GPUs inside of one large
machine so if this is a large machine
this is GPU
zero and this is GPU one this is pretty
standard because especially on Nvidia
machines they have these whatever I
think they call them InfiniBand or so or
is that so Nvidia has these connectors
that can connect the GPUs together
really fast so you can keep these in
sync but now the problem becomes what if
you want to train a model that is larger
than this so let's forget about the data
parallelism for now if that is what it's
called and just consider a model that is
too large so a model that is too large
will not fit into a machine so this is a
model as a large model so what you want
to do is you want to pack some of the
model onto your first machine and then
take the other part of the model sorry
and pack it onto another machine right
you separate the model and put it on
different machines now if you have a
batch of data what you have to do is you
pass it pass it pass it forward
propagate as you regularly would but
then you have an intermediate result you
send that to the next machine and you
forward propagate that at the end here
you have a loss right you wanna back
propagate regularly through this machine
you have an intermediate result of back
propagation send it over the network and
back prop all the way through the model
so that's how you can train a model that
is too large for one machine if you have
multiple machines the problem here of
course is this part just as you had to
keep in sync the model before now your
problem your communication problem
becomes one of you have to send the
intermediate stages to that model and
you have to send the intermediate stage
of the backpropagation back to to that
part of the model and while this
art is working this part is kind of
idling away and the network overhead
sorry is just very costly especially if
your model is so large it can't even fit
into one of these single boxes right so
this this is very this is very
problematic here it's still doable but
what the zero optimizer does is it does
both data and model parallelism so it
can train models that are too large
right too large for a single machine and
it can do data parallelism at the same
time such that basically everything is
working all the time there is no wasted
or not much wasted computation the
communication is efficient and so on so
it's really a technical achievement it's
not so much in scientific advance it's
really a technical achievement this
optimizer and will will shortly go go
through there is a kind of an animation
but it's on the website where it's super
slow and I think this might be the first
time that I will be faster at explaining
something than a video all right let's
see here
all right cool so what do you do is
let's just consider these three GPUs
before that it would all fit on one
machine but now it's say you don't
actually have that much that much memory
you don't have these these giant empty
blocks here you just have a bit of that
so you have to split your model the blue
parts here are your model right these
are these are model parameters the
orange parts here is memory you need to
store gradients right you need as many
gradients as you have model parameters
as because you do gradient descent the
green stuff here or what's called
optimizer parameters now if you just
have SGD these would be non-existent
but if you have something like a degrade
or atom they have additional parameters
for each model parameter that they need
to keep track of so these are stored
here and there can be significant
overhead there's also like a
floating-point 3216 conversion going on
here don't want to go into that all
right so you split your model onto these
three machines let's say that's your
entire model your model is six blocks
wide right and you need to forward
propagate now through everything alright
so here is what 0 does and I think it's
pretty cool so what we need to do is we
have these three different batches of
data and we want to forward propagate
them all through the model through the
same model at the same time as if the
model were actually stored on all these
machines like if all of these machines
had the entire model and we have can do
a bit of communication so what we do
first is this one's easy right data 0
through the first two layers here is
easy right because we have them right so
then you go through the first you get an
intermediate result here and here right
okay how do we propagate data one
through these through the first layer we
can't send data one here that would be
too expensive right and that's the whole
point would be lost right we want to
actually compute data one on this GPU at
at the same time what we do is before we
start we actually communicate these two
blocks here to GPU one all right we we
send these parameters around and fill
them in here I should actually make them
blue right we send them here and we also
send them here right we send the
parameters to all the machines right
then we can actually forward prop data
one through this and data three through
this right so we can do forward prop
after we've communicated all the GPUs
can be working same with layer two right
so layer two simply can send it's it's
these these two here you can see that
these two here to the other machines
right now while it's doing that we've
already propagated to through the first
layer
so we've already propagated here and
here through the first layer so we can
actually delete these again all right we
can we can delete these first layer
parameters that we sent around again
right so here's you see how we can save
memory we don't keep all the model in
sync on all the machines we send
whatever we need on the other machines
and then once the computation is done
they can delete it again right because
there's always one machine right this
one here for the middle parameters that
keeps track of the parameters and that
can at any point if they're needed send
them again so that's the big kind of
catch so you can forward prop now
through these two right they here that
are already present and then you can
delete those again on the machines where
they're not natively stored and you can
send from here you can send those to
also up here you can send those to and
and forward prop your model through to
the end right yeah that was a mistake
then each machine calculates its own
loss right loss loss loss and the
backward propagation happens in much the
same way so as you can if you follow so
far you can already imagine right what I
can do is so now this is a loss the loss
is different because there's a different
batch of data going through each machine
right so there's a different batch of
data going through each machine but each
machine has computed with the same model
due to the communic
occasion of the zero optimizer so that's
pretty cool so you get the benefits of
data parallelism right lots of data on
the different machines and you also
split up the model across the machines
but the you don't actually store the
model on any of these machines you don't
store the model you only send right from
here you send as you need and then you
delete again right and for the backward
propagation same thing right you
backward propagation you calculate
gradients now you calculate gradients
here you send the gradients as needed to
the other machines right you calculate
gradients here and here and you send
them to the Machine where they're
actually needed this is what your pen
sorry you send them to that machine that
machine will aggregate all the gradients
of all the machines what is up with this
okay it will aggregate them and then
locally it can compute using these
optimizer parameters and so on it can do
all kinds of optimization locally
because it has gathered gradients from
all the other data so what you end up
with for example GPU to here for these
two layers it has effectively broadcast
the layers such that much much more data
than it just had itself could run
through the layers it has aggregated
gradients from all of that data and now
it can use all of these gradients
together to make a good update using the
optimizer parameters to make a good
update to these model parameters and
then in the next iteration it can go
ahead and broadcast the model parameters
the new model parameters again so it is
able to compute with much more data than
it can just fit by itself and it is just
doing its part so
zero and deep speed as a zeros that I
guess the protocol and deep speed is the
actual library they will do all of this
communication and splitting and so on
for you over the network in a way that
is efficient in a way that everything
runs at the same time and the
communication overhead is minimal and
you can actually choose which stage you
want so what your trade off of
communication and memory saving will be
so this is extremely cool they say this
goes up to whatever 100 billion
parameter models if you use item this
isn't something for a you know your
average collab user this is really
something for for big players but that
being said I don't think language is
solved by simply throwing more
parameters at it I think we're still a
bit of a breakthrough there's still a
big big of a breakthrough ahead yet to
come in language understanding with
newer model architectures all right that
was it for me thanks